Where are we going to get the wealth
to build thetypes of
business that we want.
And the answer is going to have
to be cooperative economics.
There'sa lot of different
versions of cooperativism.
What I'm talking about
today is workerownership.
Right now, today,
in South Bronx,
is the country's largest
worker-owned company.
And it was founded by black
and Latinx homecare workers
who are now able to pay
themselves living wages,
they have full-timehours, they
have benefits and a pension,
through their membership as a unit of SEIU.
And these women owners now
receive a dividend back
on their ownership every year that
thecompany has been profitable,
which has been most years.
They don't have any big investors.
They don't havefat-cat CEOs
or absentee owners
taking the profit out of the company.
They each pay in about 1,000dollars over time
in order to gain ownership,
and now they own their job.
I'm so inspired bywhat they're doing,
because it really represents an alternative
to the type of economywe have now,
which exploits all of us.